Assalamu aalaykum. Walaykum. Asalam. My
name is Tanzim Ahmed. I am from Bili,
India. I am an electronics engineer.
Sir, I'm jobless. While searching for a
job, when I mention in my resume that I
am a fresher, then companies do not
shortlist my name. When I mention fake
experience in my resume, then the
company shortlists my resume and I get
the job. I want to ask you if I get a
job through fake experience letter then
is the money earned from it halal or
haram. The question posed by the brother
is that he's electronic engineer and
he's a fresher. If he writes in his
resume, his bio data that he's a
fresher, he may not get the job. But if
he writes a fake thing, his experience,
he may get a job.
So after he gets a job by writing a
false statement or a fake certificate
that is experienced and if he earns
money from that job is it haram or is it
halal right now you have to
differentiate between both these both
these are two different things I would
like to pose a question to you suppose
that the person who can't find water
what does he do he robs water and with
that water he does voodoo because he
wanted to pray he cannot find water so
he robs water and he does voodoo with
that water and he prays, will the prayer
be accepted or not? Yes or no? Robbing
is haram. So if he robs, he'll get
punishment for that. But his voodoo is
complete because he did voodoo with that
water. He prayed the salah also will be
accepted. So similarly here, if you make
a fake certificate, you'll be held
responsible for that forgery. You'll get
the punishment for making the fake
certificate. But after you get the job,
as long as you don't do anything haram
in that job, as long as you're qualified
engineer and the people happy with you,
they're paying your salary for the work
you do. So once you get that job and you
work dedicatedly and intelligently and
the company is happy, company pays you
salary, gives you an increment, the
salary is halal. But that initial act is
haram. For that you'll be punished. But
after that what you did, you didn't do
anything haram. So that first act that
you did, you made a fake certificate is
haram. But after that what you earned is
halal. It's permitted. So you have to
ask forgiveness to Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala for forging that certificate. And
if you want to go more ahead, you can
even tell your boss that once the boss
start liking you, you know boss, I will
tell you one thing that you know now I'm
working in a company for 5 years but I
will tell you one thing that a mistake
and hope you forgive me. What was the
mistake that had that afforded the
certificate if you're a good employee
now? You already experienced for 5
years. Why will he take you out? He may
start liking you also but there's a risk
he may remove you also. So if you have
done this thing you'll be punished.
You'll be responsible for one act of
forgery but the other thing is halal. If
you ask Allah for forgiveness, Allah
will forgive you. If you can go and tell
your boss if he really loves you and
likes your work, inshallah he will he
will not mind it and maybe he will think
okay now you're honest man you have come
and told me maybe we'll give you a
promotion also in